ukrainian forces leave an important
bridge in the strategic city of harrison
pockmarked but still standing
but perhaps not for long this soldier
says they are outgunned by powerful
russian artillery but determined
we will liberate curson that's for sure
we will not give it away to the russians
that's why we're here so our children
won't have to fight anymore so that we
can solve this matter now and forever
in
mobile artillery units have attacked
russian targets
the armed forces of ukraine are
advancing step by step in the region
but the war of attrition on the ground
is somewhat overshadowed by russia's
shelling of odessa's port
ukraine says it intercepted two missiles
on saturday but two more made it through
a russian military spokesman says those
missiles hit legitimate military targets
a warship he says and a warehouse filled
with american-made harpoon anti-ship
missiles
russian forces took action in a port of
odessa
a docked ukrainian warship and a
warehouse with u.s supplied missiles
were destroyed
russia used long-range naval missiles in
odessa seaport on the territory of a
ship repair plant
the attack has been widely condemned
coming less than 24 hours after the two
countries signed an agreement for the
safe passage of ukrainian wheat corn and
sunflower oil from odessa and two other
black sea ports
speaking in egypt russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov says moscow will
stick to the deal
we have confirmed the commitment of
russian grain exporters to meet all
their obligations president vladimir
putin also emphasized this in a recent
telephone discussion with egyptian
president el-sisi
if not the war in ukraine threatens to
trigger a food crisis that would be felt
around the world john hendren al jazeera
keefe